this is just an unbelievable story
after months and months of wrangling
trying to avoid providing call records
to the house committee investigating the
january 6 trump riots
the trump white house the former white
house
finally provided the call records to the
january 6th committee great right i mean
what delightful we they've got the
information they need
no
the january 6th call logs provided by
trump to the committee
have a seven hour gap
on january 6th the key hours
during which it is crucial and critical
to understand who is trump speaking to
now there's a second layer to this which
is
they may have had phone calls that they
never put in the log so there's kind of
two layers of accountability the first
is give us the log so we can see who you
spoke to that assumes the logs are
accurate
and i would not assume that with this
former administration
but the next part of it is of course
well
do the calls even reflect what what they
should reflect um washington post report
very good report by bob woodward and
robert costa january 6 white house logs
given to the house
show a seven hour gap
wow
the house select committee is now
investigating whether it has the full
record
and whether trump communicated that day
through back channels phones of aids or
personal disposable phones now trump is
claiming he doesn't know what a burner
phone is i don't believe that for a
second we're going to get to that in a
moment read the whole article we're
linking to it
internal white house records from the
day of the attack
that were turned over to the house
select committee show a gap in trump's
phone logs of 7 hours and 37 minutes
including
what a surprise the period when the
building was being violently assaulted
according to documents obtained by the
washington post and cbs news the lack of
an official white house notation of any
calls placed to or by trump for 457
minutes
look at the time here from 11 17 a.m to
6 54 p.m trying to think what was going
on during that time oh right that was
exactly when the capital was taken over
by
violent insurrectionists attempting to
overturn the results of the election
well during that time we don't have the
logs
that means the committee has no record
of his phone conversations as his
supporters descended on the capitol
battled overwhelmed police and forcibly
entered the building prompting lawmakers
and vp mike pence to flee for safety
the 11 pages of records which consist of
the president's official daily diary and
the white house switchboard call logs
were turned over by the national
archives earlier this year the records
show trump was active on the phone for
part of the day documenting
conversations with at least eight people
in the morning and eleven in the evening
but there is this seven hour gap that
stands in stark contrast to the
extensive public reporting about phone
calls he had with allies during the
attack we know he spoke to mike lee he
spoke to tommy tuberville he spoke to
kevin mccarthy and many others so in
essence they didn't really turn over the
records uh in that
we don't actually have the records or
the white house doesn't uh during those
key moments now i want to talk about
this burner thing this is now from a cbs
news article remember that this was a
kind of joint report from washington
post and cbs
the house panel is now investigating
whether trump communicated through back
channels meaning he could have used
other people's phones or personal
disposable phones known as burner phones
look at this in a statement monday night
trump said i have no idea what a burner
phone is
to the best of my knowledge i have never
even heard the term does anybody believe
that
does anybody believe that donald trump
doesn't know what a burner phone is i
know he's not the brightest
but there is no doubt that he knows what
a burner phone is the stuff that trump
has been up to for so long
now um is it possible he doesn't know it
by that name he knows it as a disposable
phone
i i don't know guys maybe maybe but this
is not believable
and when we talk about
remember when we spoke about the ukraine
fiasco that led to the second
impeachment remember when we spoke about
the entire russia probe quite frankly as
i've said before
if from the beginning of the suspicions
about russia the mueller investigation
the entire thing
much of what took place was
self-inflicted harm done by trump
if trump hadn't gone public and tweeted
all sorts of things that attracted more
attention to the story if trump hadn't
gone overboard in his denials and then
it came out actually they met with all
of these russian uh uh individuals and
all these different things the
investigation would never have become
what it was and similarly when it comes
to january 6 it is increasingly
plausible
that
had trump just cooperated
and not called attention to the fact
that he's obviously trying to cover up
the full scope of what he did and what
he said and who he spoke to that day
this also likely would not be as big as
it is
because to be perfectly frank my opinion
is
whatever is in those missing seven and a
half hours
it's probably not good
but if you don't have the contents of
those calls you have a circumstantial
case at best most likely and again the
fact that there is a seven and a half
hour gap in the records at exactly the
key time that's being investigated is
just putting more of a focus on that
time and suggesting that donald trump
knows that he did something wrong so
i'm not suggesting trump is innocent but
what i am suggesting is that the
cover-up after the fact actions
are putting more of a spotlight when you
don't give seven and a half hours of
logs you're saying these are the seven
and a half hours that you want to focus
on now unfortunately and i know we
continue to have this discussion you and
i uh in the audience
it's not looking to me like there are
going to be any consequences here number
one there seems to be no willingness on
the part of any prosecutor to actually
look at criminal charges for any of
what's taken place and number two
listen
trump is pretty teflon it's just the
reality and uh he's thinking about
running again in 2024 there's the
possibility that even running again may
be part of keeping himself out of
trouble trouble by being back in power
uh and i'm i remain
pessimistic about uh accountability here
but in the last 24 hours just incredible
stories and a seven and a half hour gap
in the phone records if you believe that
we are finally getting to where it's
overwhelming there are going to be
consequences
let me know you can find me on twitter
at dpakman and let me know what you
think is coming
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below